tonight Charles Waldheim delivers the
annual Lenihan memorial lecture in
landscape an endowed series funded by
family and friends of Timothy Egan
Monaghan Yale College class of 1980 and
Yale School of Architecture class of
1984 whose brilliant career was cut
short by death in 1994 landscape plays
an important part in the school's
pedagogy this is in no little way a
result of the generosity of the Lenihan
family who not only endowed this lecture
series but also as a memorial to Tim's
mother Lois elm Monahan and out of fund
providing resources and support of
landscape programs we are grateful to
the Lenna hands for their faith in our
school in its educational mission and
many of the family are here tonight and
we welcome them as always tonight's
Lenihan what landscape lecture is the
19th in the series the majority of those
who have delivered went on lectures have
been reading practitioners in the field
including Mario chef Nam Charles Hart
George Hargraves Michael Van Valkenburg
James corner Katherine Gustafson Audrey
on goose Kate Orff
and water hood but there have also been
some historians and theorists including
Vito Drew Pinsky Alessandra Ponte and
Mirko vanish as well as those such as
Elisabeth Meyer and Christina Hale who
combined practice theory and studio
teaching tonight's speaker Charles
Waldheim is the John E Irving professor
of landscape architecture and chair of
the department of landscape architecture
at Harvard University's Graduate School
of Design his teaching and research
examine the relationships between
landscape and contemporary urbanism the
subject of tonight's talk landscape
urbanism is the term professor Waldheim
coined to describe the recent emergence
of landscape as a medium of urban order
for the contemporary city
professor Waltham is authored numerous
articles and chapters on the topic and
edited the landscape
urban ism reader his writing on
landscape and contemporary urbanism has
appeared in numerous journals and his
path-breaking studies of Detroit as an
example of an urban industrial economy
in decay is documented in a number of
urban important publications including
case Lafayette Park Detroit which he
edited and stalking Detroit which he
co-edited with George dusk elitists and
I'm probably doing no justice to that
name and Jason young professor Waldheim
is currently writing the first book
length history of Chicago's O'Hare
Airport and we'll all be stuck there and
we'll run to the shops and buy and
probably be able to finish it before our
flight is called it will be called
Chicago O'Hare and natural and cultural
history a graduate of the University of
Florida Charles Waldheim received the
Master of Architecture from the
University of Pennsylvania his principal
of the Cambridge Massachusetts based
practice urban agency a
multidisciplinary consultancy in design
and contemporary urbanism please join me
in welcoming Charles Waldheim is a
delivers Lenna and lecture landscape as
urbanism Charles
thanks very much Bob that's very kind
it's really a pleasure to be to be back
here and to see so many old friends and
and make a few a few new ones and it's a
particular honor to be invited to give
the the Linehan lecture it's a it's an
astonishing list of 18 previous speakers
I'm confident for next year the 20th
you'll get somebody who can really do
justice to this but it's really a
pleasure to be here well what I thought
I would do given given Bob's an
invitation to speak about the recent
kerfuffle and a bit of its origins he's
organised in two parts the first part
I'm gonna rehearse some of the basic
claims some of the fundamental tenants
over the last 10 or 12 years around this
concept and then to connect them to a
few projects that are by now quasi
canonical and then a couple of other
things that are maybe slightly more
recent to illustrate the the burgeoning
kind of mature phase let's call it of
landscape urbanist practice and in the
second part I thought it would be
interesting to connect the discourse
around landscape and urbanism to a kind
of mid-century moment and talk about
some of the historical antecedents to
landscape urbanist
discourse and practice in both of those
halves I'll open with a very brief kind
of origin myth in a way about landscape
or landscape architecture admittedly of
course there are many many of such
origin myths and I don't mean to suggest
any my anyway that mine are singular but
I do feel in particular given the
ascendancy of this discourse and the
recent conversations and its absorption
into landscape architecture it might be
worth saying something about beginnings
at the end of the 19th century Landscape
Architecture was invented in America and
as a profession and as a discipline and
for the professionals and the artists
and the educators who aspired to invent
this new field I think that they had
something in mind if you read the
foundational documents which was quite
radical it was a social project it was
meant to directly address the urban the
social the environmental conditions we
would call them today for the industrial
city so within the 1890s with the
foundation of the Association and the
consolidation of intellectual and
practical capital around the idea of
Landscape Architecture the idea that it
would be an academic discipline at the
same time was quite out and over the
course of the last hundred or hundred
and ten years or so the relationship
between the discipline and the
profession have been founded on an idea
of addressing urban conditions and so
for for many of my readers and
colleagues the formulation of landscape
and relationships urbanism is putting
things together that don't belong but
for me reading the origins of landscape
architecture in North America suggests
that in fact it was always already urban
and in fact it was meant to address the
social environmental conditions now it
happens to be true that that radical
social and political project was so
successful that by the 1920s its urban
commitments so great that it swelled up
and spun off an entirely new field of
work an entirely new profession and
academic discipline city or town
planning and and I now have this view
that over the course of the field in the
last century at least as landscapes
urban commitments come to the fore they
have a tendency to impact the discourse
in other disciplines and other
professions adjacent to it with respect
to the urban arts in that regard
landscape also has a history of falling
back upon its other commitments after
the spin off of another field there was
another moment in the 1950s around the
discussion of urban design at Harvard
and other places in which some of the
initial drafts placed urban design
within the Department of landscape
architecture and so I apologize for the
inside baseball
about disciplinary and professional
origins but for the story that I want to
tell I think it's important to have some
sense of a reading of that it's its
origins and it's in its aspirations by
the end of the by the end of the
previous century there were a whole host
of english-language authors and critics
claiming relationships between landscape
and urbanism or using landscape as an
adjective modifier the origins and
etymology of that are available they're
reasonably well documented that in a
host of places in Australia and New
Zealand in London on the eastern
seaboard of the United States a range of
people a number of people in different
fields began to describe the potentials
for landscape by the turn of the
millennium Stan Allen argued that
increasingly landscape had emerged as a
model for urbanism while landscape was
traditionally been defined as the art of
organizing horizontal surfaces his
argument was that by paying close
attention to those surfaces their
conditions their materiality and their
performance designers can both activate
space and produce urban effects without
quote the weighty apparatus of
traditional space making and so a part
of the tension in the origins of
landscape urbanism has to do with the
distinction the subject object
relationship between the container the
city is a cultural artifact let's say or
as an aggregation of buildings on the
one hand as opposed to defining urbanity
of urbanism on the other hand as a set
of social relationships economic
exchange and information in this regard
of course we could look to the the late
1970s and the bubbling up of ideas
coming out of Bedford Square in
particular with the idea of
distinguishing between the architecture
of the city as a stylistic cultural
category on the one hand and a group of
people who sought to escape that
particular cul-de-sac historically and
by showing you the 1981 entry for the
parc de la Villette competitions is of
course just a cartoon of the OMA
second-price scheme we could quote
either the bernard tschumi scheme or the
or the REM koolhaas scheme
Schumi argued in that entry that the
1970s witnessed a period of renewed
interest in the formal constitution of
the city its typology
it's morphologies while developing
analyses focused on the history of the
city this attention was largely devoid
of programmatic justification no
analysis addressed the issue of the
activities that were to occur in the
city nor did any properly address the
fact that the organization of functions
and events was as much an architectural
concern as the elaboration of forms or
styles and one could cite the OMA entry
equally I think with respect to to
shifting attention to program and
activity and in fact the OMA scheme is
in fact much more direct and arguing for
the idea that the use of this particular
Park will change over the course of the
parks life and that ultimately that
change of use is something which escapes
the historical question of style and
typology in this regard the idea of the
infrastructural arrays and the idea of
interchangeability the kind of free zone
of bodies rubbing in space and the
relationship between programmatic change
over time it's meant to be delaminated
separated out from a concern for built
built space the generation following the
1970s those that were trained as
designers many of them European some in
North America tended to epitomize an
early phase of landscape or Venice
practice I'm showing you here the work
of Adrian whose West ate their shell
project in this regard hood and many of
the other landscape architects that I'll
point to this evening tend to connect to
things that hadn't always been connected
on the one hand and you can see here in
the stripes of the shell project a wink
at the OMA lavallette scheme they
connected a kind of leavened design
culture or elite design culture to
ecological function but in this regard
who's even though he had been trained at
the school at vagan again indeed Dutch
national landscape school and knew his
ecology he wasn't using ecology here to
save the world and kind of moral or
redemptive sense he was using it as a
form of public spectacle he was using a
recycled material the shells that were
found in this in this region the mussel
shells and he was organizing them in
black and white stripes knowing that the
black and white feathered birds would
tend to land on stripes of comparable
color to their coloration this was of
course a response to predation and that
through natural selection and
displaying ecology here not so much as
an operating paradigm but rather as a
kind of a medium of design equally their
project West AIDS project for buckthorn
City is interesting in this regard
using the buckthorn plant you can see
here in this section as a way to
consolidate soil at the edge of the
North Sea and construct a polder in
let's say a pre engineer or ecologically
engineered terms the use of plant
material ecological processes to
supplant what would traditionally have
been an urban configuration based on
precedent or type or use or other
externalities is indicative of this
early phase as is west date scheme for
Schiphol Airport in which the operating
ecology the use of birch and bees and
clover and honey are meant to both
mitigate bird strikes so it's
performative and at the same moment to
produce an environment which has an
aesthetic or spatial quality well it's
true that many of the early projects
were from the European welfare state
there were some early attempts in in the
North American context and of course you
know the Downsview Park competition from
from 2000 2001 would be an indicative in
this regard but both both the the gym
corner Stan Allen collaboration I'm
showing you here as well as the the
competition winning OMA scheme
illustrate the use of ecology in a set
of particular ways in this phase of work
there was a kind of fetishization of
indeterminacy and open-endedness
there was an interesting intersection of
claims on the one hand lacking any
existing ecosystem this airfield had
been scrubbed or denuded the goal was to
essentially curate ecological systems
and given the fact that there were
really very few public funds available
to build this park the idea was to allow
complexity to grow over time so diagrams
of this kind this is the work of Mina
Murray Lister the Toronto based
ecologist and planner were in early
years you begin with some birch trees
and a few frogs a natural selection in
succession will allow for a more complex
a more bio diverse a more robust public
realm at the same moment this has to do
with an intersection of public and Arts
culture the idea of design if not
celebrity at least visibility
in relationship to a kind of rising tide
of green or environmental awareness of
course that phase of work and certainly
coroner's work and others has some
historical relationship to the genealogy
of ecological planning at the same
moment while that tradition of
ecological planning is necessary it's
not sufficient to account for the
developments of landscape as urbanism
over the course of the last 10 or 15
years I'm showing you here of course as
a caricature at least Ian McHarg the
Dutch planner ecologist his aspiration
to take scientific knowledge to organise
it through ecology and to apply it to
the planning and shape of the city is of
course an extraordinarily important and
successful both pedagogic and practical
program that program has foundered for
many audiences because as it rolled out
in the 1970s with a generation or more
of landscape planners and architects
around the world was precisely at the
moment between north america we began to
undercut the welfare state and
increasingly tend toward a neoliberal
laissez faire economy and so the irony
includes that we with the invention of
GIS and mapping techniques we now have
more ecological data we have more
mapping capacity than we've ever had and
yet the challenges of urbanization
persist often because we lack the
political and economic will to implement
through planning certainly the kinds of
things that Ian was advocating for this
is a Staten Island kind of McHarg
Wallace Roberts Todd overlay method and
I think for many the McCarthy and work
is fundamental and game-changing he left
the Harvard Graduate School of Design
and three years later founded a new
department at the University of
Pennsylvania shifting what had been a
stodgy Landscape Architecture department
drawing estates and golf courses into an
idea about Regional Planning shifted
also the pedagogic of schools of
architecture and landscape architecture
the idea that scientists actual working
scientists should be appointed and that
their knowledge could be spatialized
ultimately it was a much better paradigm
for explaining where not to urbanize
than to articulate precisely how one
might be
in the city and in that regard was
ultimately I think left unprepared for
the rapid recession of planning into
social science methodology and and the
like I'm showing you here the the gym
corner field operations competition win
for also on Staten Island Fresh Kills
landfill as a transition of course this
among the central claims of landscape
urbanism or that landscape material can
clean the air and the water and the
ground of course these claims persist we
can talk about their probity we can talk
about case studies and the the levels of
science behind them but this kind of
work over the last several years has
come now to be available internationally
it's an i transcendent the discourse
that it began with and it's typify by
this kind of work in which there's an
offloading from the construction of
urban realms into natural processes
which can be predicted within some
within some range of influences or
sphere of potentialities the other thing
I would mention just in passing is the
kinds of images the diagrams here this
kind of collage work of course in the
1980s represented a paradigm shift in
the representation in landscape
architecture they no longer exist that
way today of course they're also not
nearly as digital as the work that Ian
McHarg was doing or the work that Carl
steinitz was doing at the Harvard GSD
and so landscape representation and this
kind of work ends up in a kind of funny
double bind on the one hand having more
information available and more public
currency and leavening at the same
moment we don't really yet know what the
next paradigm of representation
personally with respect to digital media
might afford at the other end of the
spectrum from Fresh Kills and the
operating cleaning of industrial sites
and waste of course we have the boutique
version we have the High Line in your
Millennium Park in Chicago and the like
extraordinarily successful public spaces
hinged around landscape using landscape
strategies and in this case a team led
by a landscape architect working with of
course really really world-class
architects and or
and planners it's also important to note
that many of these projects of landscape
urbanism at facility in north america
tend to invert the sequencer hierarchy
of planning when I went to school what I
was led to believe was that planning was
a political act that ultimately won
elected a mayor mayor appointed a
director of planning as a political
official to me they were bureaucrats and
civil servants who executed planning and
that from planning either as the kind of
planner as referee or the planners fair
broker or the planners community
activist ultimately the private public
sector relationship evolved into the
delivery of urbanism almost exclusively
the projects I'm showing you in North
America will talk about New York and
Toronto and a couple of other examples
internationally they come from a process
which is radically inverted in which
community activism admittedly robert de
niro is at your community group it's a
particular kind of community but
nonetheless this is a project that the
mayor's office and the planning regime
were dead set against until it gained a
certain buoyancy through this
combination of design and arts culture
combined with environmental awareness
that intersects now very very profitably
of course with real estate development
and you've heard the story you've been
there you've seen the success I'll
return to this in closing but I think it
is interesting to watch some of the
advocates of traditional urban form in
North America respond to the success of
the High Line I mean there was a moment
before it was built where the argument
was well it will never work and then
following its success the storyline now
seems to be don't try it anywhere else
it's not gonna work anywhere else it's
an it's an exceptional singularity the
Rybczynski piece in the New York Times a
couple of months back is indicative of
that line of thought from from a
position about neo-traditional urban
form that says landscape can't possibly
hold together as the centerpiece of an
urban district of course the math behind
this is also interesting with respect to
the amount of tax increment leveraged
relative to the original investment many
many story lines here but what I do want
to suggest is we now have increasingly a
body of early built work we have a range
of scales a range of conditions and it's
also true that in North America New York
and Toronto have emerged as
the most interesting venue is the most
complicated but also experimenting
venues for this kind of work
this is the West 8 scheme for Governors
Island of course in this regard I should
also mention the work of my colleague
and friend Michael Van Valkenburg and
his firm around the edges of Manhattan
this is appears industrial brownfield
remediation reconstructing a new kind of
public realm Brooklyn Bridge Park which
just opened this phase of it last year
kind of conceiving an entirely new
district a whole new frontage on this
piece of the city ecological function
being the driver of a new shape of urban
form in this regard Toronto is an
interesting case study of course McCart
did work on Toronto's waterfront and
many of his students from Penn went to
populate the planners and the green
organizations of the conservation
authority in and around Toronto in the
context of again a public-private
partnership that went around the
planning Bureau Toronto has been
reimagining its waterfront over the past
five or six years and they've
essentially dedicated their urban
districts to leading with landscape
architects they've got under
commissioned a half a dozen of the
world's leading landscape architects
doing work which then they subcontract
or give off pieces devolved to urban
designers and to architects of a very
very high quality and then ultimately
planning in this work is the final act
that is the design competition arrives
at a use and configuration a shape of
the city and that planners work that
process with the community and then
through the City Council to allow it to
become legal and that inversion I find
increasingly available in a range of
other cultures as well this is the
central waterfront in Toronto it was one
of a range of design competitions they
shortlisted five internationally
prominent prominent designers a couple
of years ago I think it's not a
coincidence that the only team of the
five led by a Landscape Architect won
the scheme arguing that it was a
primarily ecological piece of work they
were the only scheme the only team to
leave the heavy gauge trolley in place
knowing that this heavy gauge transit
system fueled by hydroelectric power
from the north
Canada was as close to a zero or low
carbon transit system as we have in
North America whereas all of the
celebrity architect led teams moved it
out of the way of their destination
cultural venues only the hoods led team
said that's the centerpiece of our
argument the second piece is that
recuperating of the lacustrine ecology
through the collection of the
groundwater now admittedly the
collection of the groundwater can be a
prosaic thing and ultimately there are
only so many swales that can motivate an
urban project at the scale
having said that leavening those
ecological topics through design culture
whose and West eight have emerged in
spite of his desire to be a kind of
enfant terrible at a point in his career
kind of mature Urbanists their work in
Toronto which is now rolling out as a
kind of district-wide plan ultimately
then does get to block form and built
structure through a green armas on our
armature and more importantly than the
kind of what's ondrea's term a visual
Biophilia even more importantly than the
green washing you see a kind of
functioning ecological logic
underpinning what has been ultimately in
urban urban district in this regard it
may be also interesting to mention the
the almost thousand acre lake ontario
park again gym corner field operations
and larger recreational landscapes to
support the extraordinary growth of
population in Toronto and again Michael
Van Valkenburg and his firm and team for
the lower Dawn this is the kind of
eastern side of the the city of
Toronto's watershed and you can see here
the dawn river that had been canalized
as a part of the work in the 1950s to
make the Great Lakes navigable to larger
ships and their competition winning
scheme for reprogramming the
relationship between the river and the
harbour through tripling the amount of
water to be controlled and also
producing a functioning estuary on top
of that matrix the program requires the
housing for somewhere between 30 and 50
thousand new residents as Toronto has
boom
with international immigrants Ken
Greenberg is the urban designer here
he's working with a range of consultants
in a wholly new re-engineered engineered
wetland as the basis for a new form of
community banished and banished
architect in are doing very very
interesting green and and and
sustainable building strategies hung off
of a framework that begins with the
shape of the river the the jury report
for this competition mentioned that one
of the finalists in this case this is
the work of Chris Reid his firm is
called Stas based in Boston they
produced five times the amount of
ecological function and surface area in
their project for the same site they
described again with ninamarie Lister
from Toronto their project as a sex park
for fish this is indicative of landscape
work of this kind beginning with the
species often beginning with the
celebrity species the charismatic
megafauna the moose or the coyote in
this case identifying the fish that had
particular defenders in political office
had particular grants available to
support their development and hatchery
etc and then from that sex Park
identifying how to best engineer the
interface between the river and the port
Reid and his team at Stas are here
playing with the idea that the fish
don't care what it looks like they don't
need it to be neo-traditional but at the
same moment ecological function and
leavened design culture become become
integrated with each other quite
handsomely Brown and story urban
designers there are algae walls and kind
of low carbon and zero carbon strategies
for building which are of course equally
important but the basic claim of this
phase of work is that you see the
landscape architect emerging as well
what many have called the urbanist of
our age and of course this has more to
do with not just a competition for work
these days when things are so tight but
also it has to do with which discipline
or profession is apt best prepared for
the structuring of the city it might
also be fair to mention in passing as we
look at this now kind of
increasingly mature or maybe even
middle-aged phase of landscape urbanist
practice a phase that at least one one
commentator is described as a return to
form from landscape urbanist discourse
that of course this is an international
phenomenon I'm just showing you New York
and Toronto for the for the sake of the
rhetoric brevity and clarity but I'll
show you briefly at an example or two
from rapidly urbanizing East Asia
this is Shenzhen China Shenzhen is the
the sister city on the mainland to Hong
Kong and Shenzhen in the 1970s
effectively didn't exist it was a
fishing village and it's been growing
very rapidly through a Beijing policy of
wanting it to essentially balance Hong
Kong by whatever metrics people or
dollars or both it was the site of a
design competition in the harbour Jean
hi here you can see here the old port
the ports nine years old but it's
already obsolete this is a central
business district plan of the project by
Field Operations it was a winning scheme
along with om a scheme which got second
prize and drawn busquets got third prize
what's remarkable about this was that
the ecological diagram for each of the
three was essentially identical and what
I'm seeing increasingly is a kind of
rapid absorption of these strategies
into a normative practice and at the
same moment the idea that the framework
has to do with the recuperation of these
functioning ecosystems and then off of
that the residents and business and
civic life and sports and recreation and
leisure not to mention economy of a
million new residents might be home
notwithstanding the fact that these
kinds of images are by now ubiquitous
and and have therefore lost the kind of
currency they may have once had there
are I think some interesting new trend
lines and some things I think that one
could see as tendencies going forward
with this kind of practice again in
Shenzhen this is a piece of sh engine
called long gang city it's a competition
winning scheme by the landscape urbanism
group from the AAA in London Ava Castro
Eduardo Rico they now have an office set
up in China and they're doing work like
this this is a residential district for
another 200 250,000
of the 16 finalist entries the a 18 was
the only team to do a fairly
sophisticated analysis and argument for
the interpretation of the existing bill
fabric whereas all of the other
finalists simply erased what was there
in terms of cultural heritage and Bill
fabric leaving maybe one block as a
shopping center as a token the 18
getting off a plane from London said
that they were in no position to make
the interpretive judgments and decisions
about what should be kept yet one needed
to advocate for a process in this regard
they of course also did the most
thorough and professional ecological
analysis of the site and then from a
landscape typology point of view began
to develop spatial structures based on
both regional and local precedents and
then at this moment only at this moment
do they begin to look at block structure
in built form so questions of block
dimension orientation of grid solar
orientation and gain with respect to
building heights and setbacks and
densities as a function of the
ecological goals of the project and of
course ultimately this now begins to
look a lot like the the menu or the
remit of the urban designer complan or
the urban s traditionally and this is a
part of what I find interesting and in
this kind of work is that from an
ecological underlay teams led in this
way have now gotten to a place where
they can articulate built form this
diagram I think is equally interesting
and indicative it's what they call an
associative or a parametric model they
described it to their planner hosts in
Shenzhen as an Excel spreadsheet the
brief for the competition required as
they typically do an enormous gigantic
wood and plexiglass model all of the
other 15 finalists dutifully complied
and built a thing bigger than this
podium to show the shape of the city
this was the only team that had the
courage to say that as soon as you build
the first district and the first block
in that district that model is going to
be wrong it's ridiculous to imagine
something as complex as a new city with
its ecological function a change of
program use could be described in that
way
we need more robust tools and they
propose this modest increment which was
on the one hand the left side a series
of height targets on the right side
density targets and down the downtown
the bottom
a series of codes based on block
structure and typology their argument
was that they could build a responsive
engine that would allow for
decision-making to be made following a
public conversation now admittedly that
the planning bureau inch engine was a
little puzzled as to who they would have
that conversation with given the history
of displacement and human rights abuses
and environmental challenges and I do I
do want to underscore those and we can
come back to them if you want to talk
further about them but this kind of work
is something that I find increasingly
available in landscape Ravana's practice
in terms of architectural culture it's
so you know 12 years ago and no longer
has the free song yet in let's say you
know sober urban design and planning
conversations the idea of using digital
platforms so as to emulate or simulate
the complexity of natural systems as
well as the kind of complexity of urban
systems is increasingly evident in this
regard I think one way of thinking about
this work is the collision between two
distinct and kind of improbably
unrelated yet ultimately tangential
discourses since at least you know in
graduate school when I read Eisenman
post functionalism 1974 architecture has
aspired often at the highest levels to
criticality through autonomy and through
distanced authorship and techniques of
delayed and determinacy to delayed
deferred decision-making at the same
moment a whole host of people began
reading into ecology in the 1980s and
began to read into the study of the
natural world attributes that sound a
lot like that and that moment of
tangency between the 1970s and 80s in
which the natural world could be modeled
and described as an engine for
indeterminate differentiation could
allow one a position of both criticality
leavened design culture and value at the
same moment a set of green credentials
and a kind of operational ability to
intervene in the city my colleague at
Syracuse julia's Ernie AK has described
this in part as a shift from from
appearance to performance and that's
about as good a sentence as I've seen
and in that sense obviously this is an
ongoing discourse ongoing set of
practices I don't mean in any way by
describing the last decade or so of work
to suggest that it's
sorted out nor do I mean to suggest
there's a kind of life cycle in which
things mature and then die but I do
think that's a fair accounting at least
of the trend lines the tendencies that
are that are available if you read into
the origin stories and myths about
landscape in the West there are at least
two very powerful fairly clearly
distinct lines of thought for Ian McHarg
and for his colleagues landscape was
primordial we've had landscape as long
as we've been human beings as long as
we've been cultivating the ground as
long as we've been farming as long as
we've been doing the things to tend to
the garden there has been landscape that
storyline which held through for much of
the modernist era gave way in the 1970s
and 80s to a quite distinct storyline
and one that has broad broad agreement
in both the design world and also in the
academic disciplines of geography and
landscape architecture history and the
like the the new storyline has to do
with the emergence of landscape in the
14th century as a genre of painting and
theatrical arts so if you read Dennis
cosgrove or even Ernst Gombrich or JB
Jackson on the origins of landscape they
will tell you that landscape is not
primordial it's certainly not universal
it exists in a very particular set of
Western cultures it emerged in the 14th
century as a way to decorate theatrical
displays and as a way to depict the
natural world in that regard it of
course very rapidly became a way of
seeing not only the paintings of the
natural world but a way of seeing the
world without paintings and so over the
course of several centuries landscape
emerges as a way of seeing the world
mode of subjectivity we might say and
then ultimately from that Trent
transitions into something that you
could do to someone else as a stage
so as to depict it more closely to the
kinds of imagery that was being aspired
to in this regard Cosgrove among others
has argued that landscape emerges in the
two most densely settled highly evolved
mercantile economies in the 14th century
in the Po River Valley and in Flanders
that's not coincidental for cosgrove
information others who argue that it's
an urban product we can only have
landscape through cities we can only
have landscape through the division of
labour and surplus capital and leisure
time and I wasn't sure if I was feeling
more secure or less secure just then so
it's generally agreed upon landscape
emerges as an urban by-product surplus
labour extra capital leisure time
recreation even in this regard
Yale University's own Christopher wood
argued a couple of years ago that
landscape in the West was a symptom of
modern loss a cultural form that emerged
only after humanity's primal
relationship to nature had been
disrupted by urbanism Commerce and
Technology and so as an opening to this
second part I would argue again that we
can't think landscape apart from
urbanity the two are inseparable and in
fact we wouldn't have produced landscape
except for the urban conditions that
necessitated it to extend that claim
because that claim has been fairly well
available for for several decades a part
of my work has been looking at in
addition to places that are growing very
rapidly elections in places that are
decreasing in population or shrinking
very very rapidly I don't think it's a
coincidence in those places in those
venues landscape has come to the fore
whereas in places that are not growing
places that don't have much of a Delta
or dynamic either positively or
negatively more traditional strategies
are probably having purchased in this
regard of course Detroit stands in for a
range of other urban
Editions what had been one of the
wealthiest cities in the world the
fourth-largest in the US had been a
population of two million over the
course of the first half of the 20th
century and of course over the second
half of the 20th century has shrunk to
750,000 last time I checked and we're
not sure where the floor is and that
ratio of population having lost over
half of its population from its Apogee
is of course startling and the spatial
conditions of Detroit are remarkable but
I would argue that one can find
comparable spatial conditions in almost
every industrialized city in the West
and certainly in North America in this
regard the metastasized pattern from the
1950s through the 90s is no longer
remarkable as of course four million
people live in very prosperous including
suburbs including some of the wealthiest
ZIP codes in the country and the
interior central business district the
fabric of Detroit imploded in the first
half of the century holding itself
together quite nicely imploding in the
second half at the loss of building
fabric and the construction of some very
large buildings for destination
entertainment football stadium baseball
stadium and delight now that's obviously
an economic shift and it has to do with
autumn ability and the story of autumn
ability is a little bit of an easy one
to tell in Detroit but it has also to do
with models of contemporaneity both
transit but also ways of living forms of
lifestyle in this regard I've been
interested to follow the story of
planning in Detroit and to ask the
planners in Detroit well what does one
do when unbuilding replaces building is
the city's primary architectural
activity when I asked them this naive
junior faculty member at the University
of Michigan they gave me this report the
Detroit vacant land survey from 1989-90
they were driving around in Detroit with
a sharpie magic marker on Sanborn fire
insurance Maps indicating the levels of
abandonment and decay and then Dan
Hoffman at Cranbrook of course made maps
of this kind astray ting it across the
surface of the city now even Detroit's
shrinkage and abandonment and decay
pales in comparison to other stories
available in the Western tradition and
so of course Rome would be among the the
the largest examples both in its
cultural import and also its absorption
into what becomes the invention of
landscape architecture in the West if we
look at the the origins of the
abandonment of Rome for over a
millennium Rome sat as one critic put it
like a shrunken nut within its shell you
can see here with the within the Iranian
wall circuit the territory that comes to
be known in the modern era as the dis a
batata and even as late as the 17th
century this territory was described as
a kind of lawless territory increasingly
available for subdivision and
development as a kind of interior Garden
Suburb
in this regard the transition from the
14th century coining of the term disobey
to might be after the 14th century to
sabotage Oh became a generic term for
formally urbanized territory that was
abandoned across the peninsula and by
the 15th and 16th century became a very
specific place name so that by the 16th
century we could point to this territory
within the aurelion wall circuit and
described it as the dissolute ATO of
course it would come to be named that
just at the moment of its reorganization
and and really as an entree to the
Baroque redevelopment of a renewed
papacy the accounts of this territory
the abandoned interior territory that
had such an impact on the formation of
landscape architecture many of them are
quite compelling
Charles stinger is among the most
interesting authors in this regard and
he argued that once safely inside the
walls of the Eternal City the mid 15th
century travel travelers saw before him
a cityscape not different from the
countryside he just traversed the
aurelion walls built for a population in
excess of 1 million still defended the
city but vast stretches of dissolute
atto were given over to Gardens
vineyards and orchards and much simply
lay overgrown and abandoned in this
regard in a Richard Deakins describes as
late as the 19th century / 52° of 50
species of flowers and peas growing in
the space of the Flavian amphitheater of
course that level of biodiversity got
erased in the 1870s with the kind of
national project of erasure known as
archaeology
but I digress if you follow the work of
the landscape historian John Dixon hunt
hunt has argued that maps of both the
16th and 17th century showed Rome is an
intricate mixture of gardens and
cultivated land and this interior
hinterland this interior suburban
agricultural landscape is evident in
fold a 1676 map of the city
it shows gardens filling not only the
bastions of the city walls and
fortifications but also the open spaces
between the ruins of the baths and the
temples everywhere that travellers
looked in the Eternal City
Gardens modern gardens seemed part of a
larger classical landscape of course
there are many ways of telling that
story with respect to the origins of
painting there are many arguments about
the origins of painting and I think in
this regard christopher woods claim
about the origins of painting would be
an interesting one to pursue arguing a
germanic dense forested origin rather
than the Italianate one but among the
available storylines of course is the
work of Claude Lorrain and its impact on
English gardening in the 18th century
you know Claude here shown in one of his
own self-styled glasses of course Claude
was working in the 17th century and in
the you know 16 30s through 16 60s
producing some extraordinary paintings
most of them allegorical seems assembled
for the the papacy and the elite courts
of Europe what I'm interested in here is
the practice that Claude developed of
working in plein air on detail you can
see here as kind of ink sketches of an
oak tree which is indicative of the kind
of work that would have been produced
walking through the disobey tato
on his tours in this regard
most prana colors of this describe the
impact of Claude's work not so much
through the allegorical painting
tradition but rather through its
reception in the British Isles as
Claude's work has come to be
disproportionately collected in places
like the Ashmolean Museum in Oxford
which just had a retrospective
collection exhibit there which has now
gone to to Frankfurt
and so if this storyline is true that is
if landscape emerged in 13th and 14th
century in the Pearl River Valley and in
Flanders it emerges a genre of painting
it becomes something very quickly that
one can do as a subject as a tourist one
can go on a tour and have a landscape
experience or a landscape look and then
over the course of that period of time
Claude's paintings and drawings and
etchings and engravings come to stand in
for a particular set of cultural ideals
that can be acquired and so Hunt and
many other argue that one really cannot
imagine the English picturesque or the
development of the garden ask absent the
work of Lorraine and its collection in
British Holdings and in this regard of
course I think it might be possible to
claim that what we understand is
Landscape Architecture in the
anglo-american tradition certainly from
the 19th and 18th centuries the
emergence of landscape gardening as a
public act that Andrew Jackson downing
could argue was landscape architecture
and that Olmsted could claim as
landscape architecture that was
available in the 1880s and 90s tufa
Missa plen a new profession in fact
begins not with the depiction of the
companion not with the depiction of
rural or agrarian lands but with the
depiction of lands which are formerly
urban
the discourse around landscape as a form
of urbanism has been over the course of
the last 10 years looking back at
various historical antecedents various
moments and it's it's my view that there
are a set of structural conditions that
have caused landscape to come to the
fore in the last 10 or 12 years and that
those conditions were apparent at other
moments in the 20th century and so for
me and for many others the work of
modernist planners dealing with
landscape have become quite quite
important by way of a case study in
urban residue and abandonment and the
ascendency or for grounding of landscape
I'll return to Detroit
this is Sanborn fire insurance map of
black bottom it says all buildings in
blocks 1 to 6 to be razed in 1951 to be
demolished that is in the the best
welfare state trickle-down urban renewal
the city planners in Detroit did just
that they demolished the working-class
housing of a working-class
african-american community in
it must be mine the urban planners in
Detroit through the aegis of the
federally funded urban renewal project
demolished the housing of about three
thousand sort about six thousand African
working-class african-americans black
bottom named the lower east side of
Detroit named for the rich loamy soil
down near the river but not not for the
skin pigment of its of its inhabitants
but it was a thriving african-american
community with with extraordinary social
and cultural life the fields sat empty
for four years and in 1955 they were
derided as mayor Kobo's Fields and
became a political embarrassment the
project foundered not for lack of a plan
they had an award-winning plan in fact
it won a PA planning award that that
very year it had extraordinary demand
for housing I mean Detroit was occupied
by federal troops again post-world War
two and in the 1950s around access to
housing the project foundered not for
lack of funding or lack of desire for
housing it founded for lack of a real
estate developer the the public-private
relationship required a local real
estate developer after four years
Chicago based developer called the city
planners in Detroit and said well I'm
not going to call you about this project
but if you were to call me I'd return
the call and through that process
herbert greenwald got invited to take up
development of what comes to be i think
the most successful example of a proto
landscape urbanist practice in north
america Greenwald you'll recall of
course was the was the divinity students
University of Chicago common developer
who struck up an improbable conversation
with the German emigres Mies van der
Rohe the two produced some of the most
extraordinary modernist housing in the
world and much less North America and
they took the job or Greenwald accepted
the job on three conditions the first
condition was that he said that he would
only do this if it were publicly
described and actualized as a mixed-race
mixed class community period secondly he
would only do it with his
design team and third he would only do
it with his planner Ludvik Hillary Simon
with Hilbert's himer they conspired to
produce a community which is among the
best examples of a sustainable proto
ecological community by any measure and
at the same moment they produced a
community which is far more both
sustainable and environmental terms but
also culturally leavened than either the
city or the suburbs that surround it
Hilbert Eimer of course was the was the
was that with the German planner
architect an art critic the proponent of
the new Scheck like who was arguing for
a kind of a kind of return to an
agrarian urbanism he was arguing in
images like this from the middle of the
20th century called the city in the
landscape for a wholly new conception
wholly new can conceive idea about the
shape of the city in this regard of
course he was interested in decreasing
density and working horizontally and
with the assertion of a medium that one
has to describe as landscape now the the
point that I'll return to in a minute in
closing has to do with the fact that
this is the only image of Hilbert's
Homer's work that I ever saw it in my
education this was the image that was
seared into the back of our collective
retinas as the so called failures of
modernism what was what was not
described to us was the fact this was
work from the early 1920s right the
gross thud architecture which he refuted
as early as 1929 he himself in his own
writings in his own work in Germany and
in his earlier date as 1929 argued that
this was more of an Acropolis than a
metropolis the City of the Dead and very
early in the 1930s was producing work
like this mixed tight housing on a lush
verdant horizontal carpet of landscape
he of course there was of course I'm a
momentary flirtation with that obscure
University in Cambridge Massachusetts
you you recall that before before
Harvard talked to Gropius they of course
had a short list Hutton had a short list
that included Mies van der Rohe and and
I'm I'm led to believe I think the
scholarship is quite sound that nice was
with was on the top of that list they
had an exchange which is described as as
follows Hudnut said to me swell we want
you to be
you know in charge of this new Graduate
School of Design 1937 and me said I'd be
happy to accept an offer and consider it
but I will not stand as a candidate and
had not said well it's Harvard and we
have a process and we're gonna have a
shortlist and as a result we have
Gropius and we have a tradition of
urbanism and landscape which is quite
distinct Hills and Mies and and and and
and Peter Hans and then ultimately
others emigrate to an obscure
meatpacking Institute in the middle of
nowhere and go on to produce through
academic productions like this in 1944
publication published in 1949 the new
regional pattern Hills was an
extraordinarily beloved a teacher he was
fetid every year on his birthday
so-called Hills day at the German at the
German restaurant down the street he
also had an extraordinary impact through
projects which we can only view as on
the one hand visionary but also
rhetorical right
he was literate about the work of Walter
Chris dollar central place theory he was
equally interested in his concept of the
settlement unit which has it's obvious
antecedents in both the the Anglo and
Saxon traditions he was interested in a
kind of urbanism in which transportation
and environment might be reconciled a
kind of proto ecological urbanism is the
formulation that I've hit upon he was of
course working in response to in the
wake of the Atomic Age and he also had
moments of overreach admittedly I I want
to tell you that there are enormous
challenges for somebody whose last name
is of all time to take on the
recuperation of a German city planner
and a lab coat and but what I want to
suggest to you is that we have gone so
far of laundering this work from our
collective and cultural memories that I
think of myself as part of a larger
cohort of people who are looking back at
that history of mid-century modernist
planning and saying well hold on I mean
if our aspiration is to have cities of
social justice and environmental health
which are culturally leavened haven't we
been led to a kind of false choice this
is a bit also of my own experience as an
urbanist I was given over to make a
choice between I could have culture and
architecture on the one hand in which
case I could
very very profitably proceed and have a
newfound kind of ascendancy in relevance
culturally but I would be asked to give
away the externalities the social and
the environmental at the same moment
especially in the the recent past over
the over the last 10-15 years one would
be expected by taking up a set of social
and environmental commitments to embrace
the city ISM as a moral charge and to
not really have access to leavened
design culture and so this is a case
study hilber timers work generally and
what came to be known as Lafayette Park
more specifically of an intersection in
which social justice environmental
health and cultural 11 environments are
not mutually exclusive and that has been
my response to the advocates of
neo-traditional ISM and a part of why
I've had the courage to say well hold on
before we before we before we move on
and turn the page let's look back at
this moment in time and see what might
not be salvageable in the new regional
pattern published in 1949 by Theobald
and if the drawings and the publication
text was done in 1944 and because of the
war was held up in publication Hilbert's
himer included this drawing this was a
drawing by one of his students of course
he couldn't draw his way out of a paper
bag and he regularly didn't credit his
students for this kind of work but I
think there's a long history to that
probably he illustrates the
reconsideration of the Peace of Michigan
southeast corner of Michigan around
Detroit this is ten years before he
would get the call to look at a piece of
land in Detroit so he had no idea that
there was a project here and he argued
that with the rise of the automobile
industry Detroit's population increased
rapidly but no plan was made to direct
the city's rapid growth that growth
proceeded in complete disorder the
structure of the city is therefore wrong
cannot be improved by merely multiplying
traffic facilities only a quote
structural change of the city could
bring about the necessary order we have
to understand order in the sense that me
Sandhills and their circle would have
understood at an Augustinian sense of
everything in its place in proper
proportion in relationship to itself
Hilbert's himer was of course
radicalized by the urban conditions of
the
19th century in the early 20th century
he was persuaded by the socialist
arguments early in the 20th century
Phyllis Lambert um you know studied with
Hills and know him quite well personally
and she argues that underlying his work
is a basic idea of fairness a basic idea
of access and equity to sunlight or land
or air or water he was interested
equally in the idea of an on a non
bureaucratic approach to planning and at
the same moment and ecological what we
would call an ecological driver to urban
form today
Mies in fact reflecting on hills work
described to George Danforth among
others his frustration Mises frustration
that the importance of hills work never
really was understood by an American
audience Mies was lamenting late in life
quote maybe the importance of his work
will finally come out the concerns about
energy conservation solar orientation
environmental controls these were
longtime common issues in Hill's work
and you have the sense from reading this
and reading the letters and the
correspondence that me Sandhills must
have shared a sense of frustration with
the kind of allege ability of those
proposals in the North American context
what's astonishing is that you can see
here the Hedrick blessing photographs of
the photo montage of the model
presentation hills threatened to resign
the commission three times each of the
three times being convinced to stay on
by Mies and he also only got final
planning approval by the city of Detroit
because the swing vote on the panel
happened to have been a student of his
from IIT so it's a story that almost
didn't happen
it's a German seedling it was designed
to accommodate precisely half the
population that had lived there
historically 3,000 residents in place of
6,000 residents one of the things that I
love about Lafayette Park is that it did
precisely almost everything that we've
learned not to do and in so doing
produced the best example of mixed class
mixed race social housing I've seen in
North America of course the other
interesting storyline is that it's
fallen out of history by virtue of it
being replaced by another
narrative there was of course the knees
Ian Domino there was this famous
exchange where the first plans have
Hills has all of his units marching
east-west getting the same solar
orientation fairness equity he wants
four hours of sunlight in every living
room on the Solstice and Meath of course
said I don't like sunlight in my bedroom
hills and rotates half the units to get
the kind of helicopter Domino it's a
fundamentally automobile based
alternative to the suburbs it was meant
to be precisely attractive to those
populations that we're leaving the city
the schoolteachers and the firemen and
the judges and the industrial engineers
and a few architects sprinkled in now
admittedly our cars were smaller than
and they you know the one meter
separation of the lawn from the from the
front from the paving that separation
hid more of them than they do now but
it's a place in which Hilbert Shimer and
Caldwell and Mies imagined our kids
could play and walk to school without
crossing the automobile and what's
astonishing is that they built it and
it's true I mean the social science
that's been done on this place over 30
40 years is quite remarkable I wish that
we had better environmental data
although the anecdotal and available
observation is quite persuasive there
are surveys and interviews with
mixed-race families who in 1967 describe
being at a barbecue around this pool
while literally they saw a Detroit in
flames and I don't want to be you know
saccharine about this I don't want to
overstate it or make it too great of a
claim but I'm just shocked by both the
gap in literacy within the disciplines
responsible for the urban arts and the
overwhelming success of the narrative
which displaced this kind of work which
I also want to acknowledge so this is a
head Hedrick blessing photograph 1956-57
it's a Geordi Bernardo in 1999 2001
it's a place of extraordinary
architectural character I mean
admittedly the provenance here is is not
irrelevant it's the largest collection
of Mises buildings on the planet 30 of
these buildings but the claims that the
central claims the social and
environmental and cultural claims don't
have to pertain to the architecture it's
an environment in which social
intercourse the life of the city happens
without a fence without a guard without
a gate to this very day and it's
structured and ordered through I don't
know what else to call it I think it's
landscape and in this regard I've been
interested to follow and by way of
closing I'll leave you with what was the
reception of this story in English
language discourse both sides of the
Atlantic and in particular its impact on
the debates around urbanism and the
shape of the city the project was very
well described and received in the
popular press one of my favorite pieces
was a Detroit newspaper which referred
to the designer is Miles van der Rohe
you have to imagine at this moment I
think it's fair to say I mean somebody
might be able to help me with this but I
think it's fair to say that at this
moment in time
Mies was one of the only architects in
the world who enjoyed the level of
cultural visibility celebrity we would
call it today but he was also producing
buildings cheaper per foot than his
competitors if you can find the Venn
diagram that intersects there then
that's a pretty good spot to be and I
think that that's not the only way of
reading this but there is certainly a
real estate development piece behind
this and absent absent the development
argument it's a very very different
place it was covered in the professional
press as well this article in the
professional press begins in the urban
murk surrounding Detroit's strangling
downtown so of course it was jaundiced
you know journalism and it was of course
tinged with the kind of racism that we
would expect if the day one of my
favorite pieces is this year from the
late 50s a little set of interviews
under the heading
six families with a stake in downtown
collection a kind of focused group mixed
race mixed class some school teachers a
circuit court judge somebody works in
the automobile industry occupying this
place which through mixed tenancy had a
mixture of some people who bought
condominium units cooperatively other
people who rented at market rates some
who have rented with subsidies and
others who were there with complete
subsidies the social science that's been
done on this suggests that of course
it's around Footwear and eyewear and
habits address and other customs that of
course you know class still emerges but
having said that this community you know
in a city that's eighty percent
african-american and surrounded by
suburbs that are 80 percent white it's
by far more diverse on every metric
that's been pursued at race class gender
ethnicity and the like one of the things
that I like about Lafayette Park in
addition to doing everything we've
learned not to do and getting it right
is that it was absolutely excoriated on
the Left Hilbert's himer was a committed
socialist he was admittedly less vocal
about his political commitments in North
America than he had been in Europe yet
he never relented he never really sold
out he never gave in to the the
conditions for urbanism here and found
in this one fragmentary project some
success among the critics Sibbald
moholy-nagy and in canadian architect
and if he's headed villas in the slums
she says Lafayette Park is a test case
it demonstrates problems and teaches
lessons which have nowhere been ever so
evident architectural journalism
sickening habit of obscuring facts with
a perfumed cloud of obsequious praise
deprives the younger generation of
practitioners of a much needed
opportunity to think it to learn lessons
as costly as Lafayette Park should at
least provide tuition free instruction
of course the moholy-nagy is in the
music school had their problems with
each other in America and none the least
being Lazlo's use of the term that the
so-called new Bauhaus and his subsequent
relegation to the space and the basement
of i'ts yet I don't have to rehearse
that history for you but I think
Maharaja's peace reflects a general
sentiment on the old left saying how
dare they sellout how dare they mix in
comes this should have been public
housing in this regard of course it's a
furry admired
much and Hilbert's high murmurs work yet
dismissed his one built planning project
as bushwa he argued to 4e the supreme
indifference of the transplanted Germans
made them easy prey for speculative
operations passing themselves off as
cultural as in Lafayette Park
ultimately this is pretty typical on the
journalism from front front from the far
left arguing that in arguing for mixed
race mixed class through real estate
development but somehow the project was
unrecognizable as providing any kind of
social benefit but of course it wasn't
really the the the old left although
many of them many of them made this
attack and of course others more
reasonable positions I guess Kenneth
Trant and comes to mind as would the
Smith's ins you know the the Allison and
Peter Smithson regarded Lafayette Park
calm as in an ideal and Frampton argued
that it was self effacing and yet
unfamiliar a neo rad Bernie and
juxtaposition of housing and parking
ultimately for me though of course it
was the what became the dominant
narrative of our friends Charles Jencks
and George Baird coming out of London in
1966 Jenks you know he wasn't even yet a
BD still working on his doctorate he he
writes this piece modestly titled the
problem of Mies in which he argues that
the architect Mies then that had the
greatest cultural capital in the world
his work would only be ever regarded as
minor and never major because of the
confusion of true importance and the
mistaking of a bathroom vent etc in this
regard what I've found is that for
critics who wanted to attack me I didn't
have the temerity or the poise of Jenks
of course Hilbert's heimer became the
low-hanging fruit and a whole host
dozens and dozens of critics attacked
Hilbert's himer
through images of the grouse that
architecture as the failures of
modernism as a kind of surrogate attack
on Mies and the museum school and the
museum dominance in this regard I'm also
interested to see my friend George Baird
here seventy-seven and AD eating oysters
along with rim argue that to take
another important case the current
status of the rep
of Mies van der Rohe surely except for
Ludwig Hilbert's himer today's least
fashionable modern architect and with
jinx and with Baird we see a generation
of critics who begin to critique Hills
as out of fashion and it struck me that
because neither meat nor Hills north
northern developing team said much about
fashion and yet ultimately a dominant
strain of conversation coming out of the
70s from Bedford Square London and
elsewhere comes to inform both my own
education but also our dominant ways of
thinking about this joseph rick wert in
the 1980s argued that looking back one
can only take note in astonishment at
Lud Hilbert's heimer success his barren
gloomy menacing drawings prophecy a city
without streets even worse if that's
possible then that which has already
been realized his success is a
sociological phenomenon of the strangest
kind and then of course our friend
Stanley targum and arguing in the 80s
that Mises architectural production and
his genuine humility were an unbeatable
combination particularly when they were
drummed home by a spate of books by his
humorless acolyte Ludwig Hilbert Heiner
and Stanley you know persists with the
misspelling of Port Hills name at least
half a dozen of the critics that I've
referred to misspelled his name in
various ways and essentially used him as
a way to attack what came to be known
and institutionalized as the the
failures of modernism of course by this
time we were only three years away from
Kay Michael Hayes's dissertation on
Hannes Meyer and little bit Hilbert's
himer and so that recuperation of Helms
Hills in its relationship to landscape
as a medium of urbanism of course has
its own story but I'll I'll just close
there with that conclusion in which
isn't it curious a generation or two of
Urbanists have been given over to a
false choice between design culture on
the one hand or environmental or social
commitments on the other of course that
reflects the Disciplinary fall from
grace that we've enjoyed in which
professions have diverged from one
another very very radically post 1968
it's striking to me that the obvious
successful examples that we have
available have fallen out of that
narrative in favor of a narrative in
which we've convinced ourselves that
modernist architects
sure failed the city in that respect I
think it's maybe collateral damage that
landscape also suffered by falling out
of the equation and yet I think a
critical enlightened rereading of some
of the most successful examples of
modernist planning suggests that
landscape has been a medium of urban
order for some time and maybe with this
for some time in the future thanks very
much
Thank You Charles
this electric could be called first
you're hot then you're not then you come
back again maybe if you wait around long
and waited up with long enough or
whether you didn't wait long enough 7up
I'm sure there's some questions for our
speaker I'm hoping there are some
questions
Eduardo okay we can always rely on
Eduardo make it a question in Eduardo
and short and easy what do you think are
the challenges of the discipline of
landscape urbanism could you could you
do the front-end again yeah okay what do
you think if you can share with us what
are the challenges that the discipline
faces after this triumphant description
after this the economy's not great I
think it's clear by now that I think for
me at least we don't really see a
disciplinary shift but rather a set of
practices and so degree nomenclature
profession or professional license or
these kinds of things will probably
persist but right now there's an
increasingly interesting bubbling up of
different disciplinary and professional
credentials with respect to who gets to
lead and so on the one hand there's a
kind of leavening a leveling of
different hierarchies and so for
landscape architects that have often
been reliant for their livelihood and
their station on a trickle down from
architecture and from urban designers
and planners this newfound confidence
has a kind of economic structure
underneath it and at the same moment
landscape is responding to some of the
cultural but also economic conditions of
these cities
so for me I think the economic
underbelly is the thing it's the
storyline and it's the driver at the
same moment I think another
vulnerability has to do with the
relative half-life of ideas in our field
you know I mean in in at the elite level
in architecture if you don't have a new
stick every 18 months you're essentially
out of business and I understand that I
don't I don't mean to dismiss it I don't
think it's not real I think it is real
as a cultural construct and so the
disciplines move many of them at
different speeds they have different
half-life for ideas and I do think I
mean our project is to to give you know
kind of leading maybe even avant-gardist
or critical architecture and urban male
you in which to work and at the same
moment if that architecture gets so far
away again or goes so far into its own
self construction I think we could lose
something you know and so those two
things the economic underpinnings of the
operation and this approach monke
between the fields either of those are
vulnerable I think Joel wait we need a
mic well thank you for coming and yet
again to Yale and for delivering such a
powerful lecture you clearly proved your
claim that you can't think landscape
without vanity but there was also a
sub-theme that you can't think you know
landscape without without thinking about
its many forms of representation
particularly in depictions as you said
in relationships between or and
landscape and your description of
earlier modes of representation may be
kind of fast forward even to thinking
about relationships let's say between
land art or between architects like
Smithson whose interest in process and
history was I know influential for it
for subsequent generations of landscape
architects but also his representations
as diagrams through film and there was a
moment when you also talked about
collage I thought in a frustrated way
and and I got the sense that that same
frisson it doesn't seem to be happening
today but there was a suggestion that
maybe digital representation
might i inferred might have the
potential to have that transformative
effect and so i just wanted you to
elaborate what I thought was a kind of
very interesting thanks that you mean I
appreciate that um it's not that I
lament that moment but it's on the one
hand true I think it's self-evident that
you you can't have landscape without a
representational program or multiple
representational programs it depends
upon a complex economy of subject and
object and valuing when landscape comes
to the fore at various historical
moments it tends to do that around a new
representational paradigm often and I'm
not arguing that the representational
paradigm leads to send them say that
maybe it's a dialect and so if you were
you know if you're in Philadelphia in
1989 and you saw the impact of the
historical avant-garde being reread by
70s and 80s architects being absorbed
into landscape that was a very powerful
moment when those two worlds collided
and it was like well ecology and this
representational program might have
something to do with each other having
said that I think those tropes have
exhausted themselves and we see a world
filled with you know it's ignition
season you know and so you see a world
filled with the reproduction of those
cliches by now and in part this is a my
day job now is I think that we need to
do better as a discipline you know when
Landscape Architecture ran away from
design culture for some period of time
had different tools than architecture
and urban design and planning we didn't
always benefit from that and so there's
a kind of argument about protection of
the discipline and identity through our
tools being distinct as opposed to
sharing and so we're involved in a
series of experiments right now at the
GSD looking into which aspects of the
recent you know kind of interest in
digital media might be relevant for
landscape architecture it's a really
early stuff it's I don't yet have a talk
put together about it but there are
glimpses that you can see when McHargue
was doing analog overlay you know
acetates manually in philadelphia some
people in the basement of Memorial Hall
at Harvard were inventing GIS
so I'm a million-dollar grant from the
Ford Foundation in the 60s to do
computer mapping essentially changed the
ways in which planners and ecologists
viewed the world and yet that storyline
kind of fell out and when I arrived in
the department at 2 and 1/2 years ago
there was a prohibition against the
computer and the studios and we had one
digital course and and so on the one
hand it was just a basic literacy
question but if the more interesting
edge of it I do think not simply because
they're digital I don't mean
teleologically but I mean because of
what they can do I do think that some of
the tools that have been developed in
the last decade in other fields relevant
to to landscape might have some
cross-pollination that might be
interesting I don't know whether you had
a chance to read Michael Kimmelman
article in today's paper that was also
in some way doing what you're doing
which was indicating that the fall of
pruitt-igoe as a you know indication of
the all the faults of modernism and all
those things how unjust that was and
then he actually was looking at it
affordable housing in Chelsea in New
York as an example that showed that that
kind of public housing was with the
right finances and with the right
maintenance all these different things
was successful so in some ways part of
the recuperation project that that
you're doing which is great but on the
other hand in in emphasizing that has to
do not with the architecture but it has
to do with the support with the
regulations with the financing all those
things it under it undercuts the value
of design and exactly the the example in
Chelsea has very little design and so
I'm wondering how you having the same
social political sympathies
when did you read did you get anyway I
hope I'm describing us and comment on it
I see is a discussion that doesn't
actually talk about design or in that
particular case doesn't talk about the
relationship with the buildings to the
land
and the design which is in fact in
Chelsea quite intricate so anyway I'm
wondering whether yeah I'll read it I'll
read it tomorrow morning it gets there a
day later I was I was pleased to learn
moving to Cambridge Massachusetts that
we we get our New York Times on Saturday
and Sunday too you know I've heard
clears customs no I think it's an app
it's an app set of questions I mean I
think that you know but between you know
st. Jane and and George and and and
Charles Jencks and and and and on the
one hand and and our friend Tom Wolfe on
the other we've internalized this
narrative that it was architecture that
failed us whereas I think yeah of course
mistakes were made is that the
formulation and of course but at the
same moment the aspiration to address
social and environmental challenges
through you say design or through
architecture or through planning I think
is central to this question and I I
think that on the one hand there are
clearly values and attributes you can
associate with Mises involvement in that
project the separation of the ground
plane the rotation of the Domino that I
described there's a half a dozen things
like that that simply wouldn't have
happened without that level of
architectural culture though the curtain
wall is delirious it's unbelievable it's
that kind of singing vibrating
proportion but the social and the
environmental benefits don't accrue to
that in order to the land values because
we know that you know most you know
prominently designed you know housing
tends to have its value reduced right
it's less than its typical market value
because of design being attached to it
and so in that regard
before we focus on the architecture I
want to take a step back and look at the
spatial structure and the kind of
concept of spatial structure
underpinning it and so basic things like
reducing the density by half now of
course it's an historical accident that
population of Detroit went to 50% and
it's gone smaller than that
but Hills new fundamentally the city
would disperse and even though he was a
committed socialist he quotes Henry Ford
and arguing that the city's going to
depopulate and so not imagining that
design is going to stop that but rather
using design to insulate populations
from its effects and so I'm interested
in Hills relationship to capital in that
regard because he was he was clearly you
know clear-eyed about its impacts and
yet he thought of designed not so much
as resisting but kind of insulating or
incubating you know and to see larger
structural forces and flows in which
design could be situated of course the
the maintenance of the place right its
supervision and its cultivation
especially given the plant material is
another important story that's embedded
there which again speaks to the mixing
of classes so that there are some people
who have the means to be there it has
become a bit of an architecture ghetto
statistically I mean it's it's not like
the caboose Ian projects on the
continent but there are you know
specifically far too many designers and
engineers who live there but at the same
moment it's a place that's obviously
been cared for I think design matters
maybe but not necessarily just the
architecture and then Diana after I said
so I'm just the you mentioned this idea
of translating from appearance to
representation which i think is a really
critical component of landscape urbanism
it is the notion of and the importance
of shipping shifting partly from from
from appearances something that's
functioning ecologically and and I think
that there's you know this has been a
push and pull in the field of landscape
architecture and there's as you're
saying history where it shifted back so
that aesthetics became a priority like
when I was at the GSD with George
Hargreaves perspective you know versus
more historic angles and and more recent
angles and I'm just curious about what
the role of the designer is in in
playing this in translating ecology or
social ecological components
you know how far into that arena those
other
is the designer expected to go and and
and if I feel like there's a next wave
coming that goes beyond this dilemma of
representation being the where this
plays out whether this representation
that corner or others bring up actually
represents something that's that
actually has more ecological function or
value than another perspective and part
of the challenge I would say coming at
this from as an urban ecologists and
scientists partly is that scientists
don't know the answers about how you
know about how setting up a system is
going to function in an urban context so
there's lots of unknowns and in a way
the designers have moved up in front of
the scientist in building on their own
assumptions about system functioning and
and there's one idea that we're setting
up something new and we can see how well
it works but you know there's also a lot
of costs in that and I'm wondering what
role should the designer play in that
relationship as scientists kind of catch
up and understanding the urban systems
translating science to design there's
there's a lot that we don't know it's
true I went to a conference a couple of
years ago as they happen to have now
which are like two days one day
designers one day ecologists right
that's a kind of set piece and the one
that I attended had like like serious
scientists day one and they presented
their science and the conclusion of
every paper you could anticipate after a
few of them which was we need more sites
for study and funding for study okay
the second day the architects and
Urbanists got up there and the ecologist
in the room their jaw hit the floor they
saw the world just going to hell and it
just at that moment dawned on them that
the Urbanists were helping along the way
and the architects at the end of their
paper would say give us something
give me two rules of thumb it's Thursday
I'm gonna be in China next week I've got
to give me something now right and it
became clear to me at that moment not
just the Disciplinary and cultural
differences but the profound challenges
of wrangling science relative to design
you know after 68 broadly speaking many
many schools of planning were
radicalized around social agency and
many of schools of
and scape were radicalized around
ecology rightly so but that had an
effect on other disciplines as well and
as architecture exported so an autonomy
through the 70s the disciplines the
professions were kind of going in these
directions and for many of my colleagues
on the planning and landscape ecology
side their basic paradigm was shaped by
scientific method the acquisition of
data the spatialization of that data to
inform better decision making and that's
the thumbnail I'm sorry if I'm doing
damage to somebody's life work in the
audience and it's not my work but I I
mean let genuinely it's an important
body of work and Ian mate might stand
for one moment in it the challenge has
become that every project I consult on
how we have more data than we could ever
put about gathering information
it's that interpreting that information
and making decisions about the economics
and in politics and in that regard we
have a political economy to play North
America in which it seems less and less
likely that we're going to be making
decisions spatialize on those decisions
about the shape of the city relative to
that environmental information and so I
think for many there was a kind of
generational crisis and when I look at
whose and corner I think that they both
were trained in a paradigm ecology which
was about putting back because the
models of classical ecology had to do
with the world in which human beings
were the problem I mean as images of
Staten Island and the NASA shots mccard
described us as the cancer on the planet
cities are the problem and there's a
very long intellectual tradition of that
in the West that he embodied in which
we're the problem right and to reconcile
that with urbanization seems quite quite
challenging and so I think it was maybe
who's in corner and a generation of
designers literacy about ecology but
frustration and simply using it to try
to put back through the welfare state
and a political climate you know post
Reagan post Thatcher in which it was
clear that cities had their own agency
and the ascendancy of design culture and
in that they they argue or I would read
into them an argument that says it's
through design agency but change can
happen is it true that design outpaces
the science to support it probably the
question that would be well what's the
alternative and its implication for
pedagogy that you mentioned you know my
department at the GSD has been
characterized by a very very
long-standing war between
and design and as of two years ago we
declared the war over and at the same
moment given generational transformation
we can say to split a school of design
that way seems absolutely the wrong
place to put the knife that it's the
leavening of ecological knowledge into
design that seems to be the currency
here and it's it's a curious place to
get to for many audiences especially
those that you know thought of their
work as using science to put back or
protect what was there Annabel Mari we
have one more you you're just the last
questions oh no ed Mitchell is dying to
speak afterwards all right a couple more
okay one of the comments I want to make
and I would like your your response is
that specifically in that Lafayette
project we're looking at a non
expressive this complete lack of
expressiveness for the landscape I mean
the architecture is very well defined
the spaces are well defined by the
architecture there is absolutely nothing
that speaks that landscape exists there
and yes the trees has grown over time
and socially you can say yes it's you
know it's it's an enormous ly
interesting experiment but from a point
of view of saying that you know that is
anything that any idea of landscape is
being represented except for density
it's it's you know quite absent there
has been a lot of writing about the fact
that the work that me stood in in
Germany has in fact had you know
represented landscape that certainly
wasn't in here so that was one aspect
it's a representational aspect but a
very important one the other separate
point no I think I'll leave it at that
so it is that a question I wanted a
statement inviting a response
yeah I am I have to respectfully
disagree I mean I really will go to the
mat on that that is landscape period
full stop I didn't show you the
flowering bulbs and I didn't show you I
understand let me let me let me let me
finish I didn't show you the vegetable
gardens I didn't show you if I wanted to
be tough in the chapter and Journal
article ever written about it I was a
little tougher the their landscape
architect architects Caldwell who did
the plantings was their weak link
because he channeled a kind of Jen's
Jensen kind of transcendentalism and so
you look at the architecture you look at
the planning it's absolutely
contemporary the aesthetic the aesthetic
of the landscape its spatial structure
is absolutely derivative there's very
little I could say that's innovative
about that now to say that there's no
landscape presence I have to disagree
because the spatial structure is given
by the landscape material the structure
of the park the structure of the
circulation the buildings are often
mostly camouflaged in fact now we can
parse into the evening I'm hoping what
we mean by landscape because that's a
conversation that I enjoy having but I
would go pretty deep pretty deep into
the evening defending that as a robust
landscape please in I wanted to simply
carry the point then also you are sort
of proposing it's not a suburban ISM
with this and I just think that there is
a point for Detroit to go to suburban
ISM right now but when what we are
looking at today is having to deal with
enormous density yeah again I'd like to
stay up late at night parsing suburban
and urban I mean my friend Sebastian
Mello in Paris has argued in a text
called landscape suburban ISM that you
can take the the genealogy of OMA and
divided into two categories of work kind
of super urbanism taking a building the
cocoon stalled Seattle Library
and simulating the free zone and density
of program in in one building of the
city and then another kind of worker
kind of suburban ISM the Melanson aren't
la Villette the horizontal stuff and I
would be willing to give a little ground
on urban suburban but what I would say
are that the qualities of urbanity that
we could describe then become really
important machine so would you measure
this by density of what social
interaction I mean there is something
which is about density not being in the
control of the planner
there's something here fundamental that
Hills not having the hubris to imagine
that he's gonna dictate autumn ability
or not because he knows these are
structural forces he will not impact
them through his planning and that
planning's role or designs role is to be
literate about those structural forces
and if the city's depopulating for
obvious reasons design is not going to
stop that what design can do is be
appropriate and responsive to it and in
that regard I think to ask a project
like this or any kind of social housing
to reverse a trend toward autumn ability
for example might be asking the wrong
question it's the corollary to the idea
that we've convinced ourselves that its
architectures fault the concentration of
poverty in pruitt-igoe and its
pathologies but ultimately use it a
different kind of urbanity is it is it
horizontal yes but I do think that it
has urban qualities it has a civic
mindedness and a collectivity certainly
but I think one could care call we could
debate that later I'd be maybe I won't
take everyone's dive with that but I
don't think that's what's exactly
lacking the psychological activity is
the last question maybe it's a good one
for you to make a kind of final response
looking at the images on the wall and I
have no argument obviously with
Lafayette Park it's one of my favorite
pieces of anything the argument that was
made in postmodern would seem to be more
nuanced than maybe you're giving it
credit for in that in generalization in
general terms it was thought that the
end of a certain mode of thought that
modernism represented
would turn towards something more
contested contradictory individual and
also involved in issues of
representation as a dominant cultural
form rather than an rationality or
ethics on the other hand most of the
work that we saw tonight really was with
maybe exception New York city-based and
cultures that are still attached to a
modern project Toronto and China given
that those those paradigms is
specifically in the rest of North
America and they are obviously contested
culturally what do you see the
particular challenges for landscape
architecture to deal with that and this
would challenge certain things probably
going on at Harvard with a romance of
parametric's is an all-knowing machine
to generate super rationality and
through through excesses of information
your experience may be in practice two
of the difficulty of actually realizing
the projects given the political climate
and economic climate of the situation in
hand I'm glad you stopped there because
I had the three and I was going to lose
it if you went to a fourth okay so first
things first I think the point about the
exhaustion of modernity or modernism is
apt I think it's a more complex story
than this yet at the same moment a part
of this was my frustration of hearing
the trope repeated uncritically over and
like it's as if we you know if you look
at architectural culture or maybe
architectural theory in history things
have gotten you know more nuanced and
changed on a regular basis but if you
look at urban design and urbanism
programs and the narratives that they
tell themselves and repeat to students
it's remarkably unreformed and it's it's
kind of rehearsing certain set-piece
these arguments and so I don't think
it's really if evolved that much it's
not actually gotten that nuanced and at
the same moment the relationship between
the the idea of having an urban model
and what's to be implemented has been I
think conflated you know I think that
there's this idea that oh well look at
Hills drawings did he actually mean to
erase all of southeastern Michigan I
mean I I don't think he did if you read
Road and the projects that he actually
engaged upon of course there were limits
to in problems with modernity my other
my other Achilles on in this is somebody
will eventually say well yeah okay maybe
if you ended up with the right developer
who went to Divinity School and if you
ended up with the you know the Marxist
planner who built one thing and in the
German if you at all everything aligns
and then lightning strikes you get this
singularity right and I think well yeah
I'd have to give a little ground there I
mean I think why is it that it hasn't
happened in a lot of other places and a
part of it has to do with the
misalignment between housing policy and
a social agency that required the
development team to stand up and take
the leadership position so I I think I'm
sure I'm being fair I mean I think to to
the the characters from the sixties and
seventies that I'm quoting I think I'm
calling it like they were describing it
and at the same moment I think it's fair
to view this as a project I think their
project was to take down the you know
the the modernist moment and they did it
very effectively and at the same moment
for very good reasons let's say and that
was maybe collateral damage I don't
think that they meant to obliterate that
piece of history but I think it
effectively worked that way um so with
respect to I've now lost the middle one
before you get to the Harvard parametric
one overlaps into the interest of most
landscape Arctic all right yeah yeah
universalism Yale okay I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna put Toronto and shinjin in the
same basket just yet I think I can more
easily source New York in Toronto I mean
they have a couple of things that make
them character they're the largest city
cities in their respective countries
they tend to be the media capital of
their respective countries they have
enormous enormous well-developed capital
markets they also have pressures for
housing they have certain kinds of
affinities in that regard and so I I
made this reference recently to you know
Lou Ann skate urbanism working in the
most highly evolved capital markets for
housing having large brownfield sites
and having this comp this weird
combination of some form of
environmental interest green audiences
interested in arts and culture and a big
enough capital market to drive housing
at a high level that seems to be the
and then you know our friends the neo
traditionalists are working in flyover
country you know it's the kind of the
milwaukee's of the world that we're
there you know and I think that that's a
structural relationship because of the
scale of market the way in which they've
been focusing on the suburbs and
incremental suburban housing
developments and the like Shenzhen is I
think a different kettle of fish but one
of these I'm trying to show is that for
me the the medium is relevant in places
where you're depopulating and places
where you're rapidly growing but medium
may be responds differently right in
terms of density or different kinds of
strategies but I think that the
structural response to a set of
industrial post-industrial and economic
conditions seems to be showing up in a
lot of different places and I think we
we could parse it you know traditional
city versus new city but I do think that
there is something about increasing
amounts of data whether it's parametric
data or not being made available to the
shape of these things there are enormous
challenges of developing projects of
this scale but the thing I would leave
you with is that compared to the
aspirations of the generation or two
before of planners this is a remarkably
more modest project I mean the problem
with the McHarg an agenda was it took
regional analysis and it tried to
implement at the scale of the region or
the metropolis and we just don't have
the political or economic structure to
do that these projects say let's do the
regional analysis understand ecology
situated in the way that they are
let's intervene at the scale of the
project site so the scale of these
projects are driven by the kind of
brownfield that they have available to
redevelop and for many of my friends on
the Left many my scientists they think
well what's the point if we can't put
the whole thing back together what are
we talking about and so for that I would
happily push that line of argument
because I think it separates us out into
the you know the voluntary human
extinction society on the far left who
you know if you go to the far left you
get to the elf the guys blowing up ski
ski ranges and golf courses you keep
going as the voluntary human extinction
group who says we should just stop
populating the planet because we're the
problem there's been an enormous power
line shift in the way that people think
about ecology and we've moved from a
classical model of ecology to a more
postmodern more contested highly
problematic one but within that ecology
is available in various ways to be in
service of these kinds of
Jackson they're big challenges both in
Toronto and New York and elsewhere but I
think it's a fight worth fighting
I think we've exhausted our speaker and
he stimulated us at the same time so
we'll thank him and continue the
discussion up there